you're watching slight coming up on the
show this week going wild how drones and
camera traps are keeping animals safe I
turned citizen scientist with the app
snapping live pictures in the wild and
in this week's games review we take on
the persona of a wild cat welcome to
their SL London Zoo the world's oldest
scientific zoo this place is more than
180 years old but the research they're
doing here is truly cutting-edge and
it's having a major impact out in the
wild his will keeping an eye on animals
in a zoo is fairly easy but monitoring
them in the wild is much more difficult
here at zsl london zoo they've developed
a system that uses satellite technology
to keep track of wildlife anywhere in
the world so far instant detects popped
up in Antarctica to observe penguin
colonies and in Kenya it's being used to
warn rangers if poachers are nearby this
is our wireless camera trap very robust
we put it in an aluminium case and it
sends photos in real time anywhere on
the planet over the iridium network
towards here in London I'm use it for
our citizen science work we can have a
look at what's going on in the wild we
can monitor populations in this case
penguins specifically it's fantastic
piece of technology that lets us
actually get into the field itself
drones are also making a big impact
they're being used to track rhinos in
Kenya and even identify potential
poachers and over in the USA animal
rights group PETA has been using drones
to clamp down on illegal hunting
vultures now know that they can't get
away with murder they know that they are
not isolated in the woods away from
human contact it's quite possible that
PETA and our drones are watching them
monitoring them and observing them for
any illegal activity one of the most
established forms of technology used by
conservationists is GPS settle the lion
who has recently killed in Zimbabwe by a
hunter wore a GPS collar for over 15
years but information collected by
scientists can sometimes end up in the
wrong hands a few years ago and we
caught a photo was arrested in can
with night vision equipment and GPS
units with the last locations of rhinos
court riders from butcher them do it so
long as he obtained so every time
they're getting more advanced and where
they are correct and our field teams
need to get one advances in response
like most zoos this place wouldn't be
here without help from the public so
it's really important that people know
exactly what they're looking at well gem
has been testing out an app designed to
turn all of us into conservationists so
this is an app that lets users see live
pictures of animals in the wild exactly
yeah so it's a called instant wild and
it's a citizen science and public
engagement app so it's a great way to
teach people about species ecology and
conservation issues and how does it help
you to do your job at the same time yes
an a public kin selection image and
identify that image and those that dice
data is then used to help build up a
species list for a particular areas so
whether and I species absence and
presence within particular areas and
also helps us and spot when there's
endanger species cited on okay well I
have spotted a giraffe so I'm tapping on
that yeah and then do i go to identify
identify yet and then you scroll across
the identification list there it is
right so you press that and then that's
logged in our database and then we can
use that data and yes to build our
species that's a fantastic photo where
are these cameras hidden yes I we mainly
strap them to trees or I got 18 x yeah
we got on here and so it's a
motion-triggered camera or a time-lapse
camera so if an image is set to take her
an image at a regular interval so when
an image is taken its sent by mobile
networks into the app and we do have a
few issues with their mobile signal in
some of these areas they're very remote
so we've started developed our satellite
enable camera trap so is this a
different camera to the one we just saw
in Wills piece it is yes a the one you
saw in was pieces one we've actually
developed because of issues around
mobile signal we want to develop a
solution where we can deploy cameras
anywhere in the world and get them in
real time and you're going to try and
roll out more with those exactly if you
have a court any amazing
sightings on these yeah we had some
amazing sighting so we've had a lot of
endangered species for example they
critically endangered job and leopard on
our Indonesia camera that a black rhino
putting endangered black rhino ever also
had a small mammal called a mountain
male steer on our Sri Lanka camera and
it hadn't been cited for several years
it's very rare until it was sighted on
instant world fantastic good to talk to
you thank you will be gaming in just a
moment but first here's a bite sized
chunk of some of this links other tech
news here's a new way to access
everything you need while driving
explore ID is a display that allows
hands-free access to maps phone calls
texts music and can even tell you how
healthy your engine is it responds to
gesture recognition so you don't need to
press any buttons the team behind it is
using crowdfunding to try and bring it
to the mass market a UK startup has
developed an app designed to create
truly custom fitted bras by using the
camera on your phone or tablet to take
over a hundred measurements without
taking any photos here's thought up to
eighty percent of women are wearing bras
that don't fit properly the app which
uses autodesk 3d design software
launches on kickstarter in early
September an engineer who featured on
swype earlier this year has been back in
the news after his prototype of a 3d
printed robotic hand won the 2015 UK
james dyson award bristol-based Joel
Gilbert's technology could off the
amputees a cheaper and quicker
alternative to other bionic limbs the
smart home security market just keeps on
growing a camera that makes its own
decisions based on what it sees and
hears inside your home while you're out
launched on crowdfunding site IndieGoGo
this week butterfly only records when it
detects something out of the ordinary
and sends you a notification now we
wanted a stick to our animal theme for
this week's games review so we asked
Chris light to pick a few of his
favorite wildlife titles and here they
are so shelter two is made by a small
company called might and delight
and you play a mother links looking
after four links cups so the idea of the
game you begin in the bar oh you name
all your little curves which is
instantly going to build attachment for
what comes later on because you have to
hunt for them I things like rabbits deer
stuff like that and then you have to
like go out and protect them as they go
out of the den they walk through the
world with these are these things like
wolves that will try and attack your
cubs and you go through the entire life
cycle with them like if they start
running out of food they will die they
will get eaten by things like eagles
they'll just fly in and eat your Cubs so
you learn all about like the cycle of
life and it's got a beautiful palette
like to the game the soundtracks really
relaxing and you can even have a family
trees all right when you finish that
cycle one of your Cubs that survived
would then become the mother herself and
keeps going you get a nice little family
tree
animal crossing a new leaf is the latest
in the animal crossing series from
Nintendo it's a game on the portable 3ds
where you play a young man who turns
into a village and finds out you're the
mayor of the village and the village is
populated by loads of little animal
friends that you get to hang out with
all the time and you go around like
digging up plants making your garden
decorating your house and there's a
particular koala in my village called
melber who is really nice like will send
you really nice letters and so far every
now and again you can send her little
layers send your little presence and
it's just a really relaxing game it's
sort of reminds me of just sitting in a
nice garden and relaxing which you can
do because it's on a portable system so
you can do that and play the game good
times economy is it's a game made by
Capcom it came out a little while ago on
the PlayStation 2 it recently got
remastered you play as a Shinto Sun God
Amaterasu is a white wolf and it's sort
of like a Zelda kind of game but set in
ancient feudal Japan so you learn about
all the various gods and things like
that and amateur ass is trying to bring
the Sun back to the world right i mean
color back to the world with a sort of
magic paintbrush thing which is cosmic
paintbrush something like that is it's
cool however it works well basically you
go through the world sort of lighting it
up and making it natural and beautiful
again and like i said it's like zelda
but like whisper it don't tell anyone
but i think a bit better like sounds
great but you're a dwarf in this thing
which is great
that's it for this week take a look at
Sky News on mobile and ipad for some
bonus features from this week's episode
I'll see you again next week bye-bye